how you doing I'm surviving yeah I'm
still here
yeah Brett first of all being here
tonight being nominated with me was sure
I know it's something to take in it is
you know what
no one you're always a joy and I do I
really like being around you thank you
thank you she loves that she loves that
okay the obsession the world the
internet everyone is waiting they're
hoping for this moment where you and
Jennifer run into each other so they can
take their picture she's a good friend
so they can you know how this goes
important reunion every of her year you
know how that works play on friends and
then they were saying that anyways it's
all about me and you everyone that
started you study
you know usually anyone who stands next
to me usually usually reported as oh
well it's gonna make Ozzy so English and
he's a great guy what would it mean to
win tonight no not necessary I mean it
you know it's it's such a subjective
thing and it is it's just a nice this
like this time of the year we all get to
come together and see we don't see each
other all year we all go off in foreign
lands and make these things and we had
to come together and say hey I really
like your work and after that yeah
yeah does that translate yeah here's my
real question here's my real question
we're the same age how come you still
have all that damn here I don't know but
you're getting up in the middle oh yeah
we're there too
[Music]